big thank you today to lisa kline warts
lisa's today's new member of the day
this program is mostly funded by
individual viewers and listeners when
they go to WWJ Ackman comm and sign up
click that red sign up button and lisa
kline ward is today's new member of the
day also want to say thanks to Jen
Steinberg Jen Steinberg a friend of mine
down in Austin Texas who has been with
the show for almost five years with
peace and love hi to Jen and Matt
Steinberg you are great great people and
maybe I'll see you in Austin soon if not
back up in Massachusetts ww join
pakman.com lisa jen thanks to everybody
and very exciting news by the way
about membership which i want to tell
you about next last week no it was the
week before and maybe it was even three
weeks ago I don't even remember now a
David Pakman show
all-star named Joshua who's a member who
participates on the YouTube live streams
with super chats got in touch and said
David I want to do something for the
show let's give away some free and
half-price memberships and I said if you
want one of these reach out to me we've
got a nice budget provided by Joshua and
we ended up with 32 new half-price
memberships and a whole bunch of free
ones I don't reven remember exactly how
many more than more than 32 for sure we
are doing this again the success of this
has inspired Joshua and us to do this
again okay so this is really really
simple
if you genuinely can't afford even a few
dollars for a membership get in touch
either on our website or just email me
directly I'm personally handling this
david at david pakman.com and then say
hey David I really want one of those
free memberships I'm not going to ask
for your tax returns you're not running
for president here I'm just gonna take
you at face value that you really can
only afford the membership if it's free
in other words you can't afford a
membership at all if you can afford a
half-price membership okay get in touch
and say David the full price member
ship is too much half-price membership
sounds good you can keep the half-price
discount for as long as you remain a
member I would like one of those david
at david pakman.com or use the contact
form on our website and i will send you
a code for a half-price membership
obviously I have no way of knowing but
last time it seemed like people were
being pretty upfront about whether they
could afford a half-price membership or
whether they really needed the free
membership just remember every time you
ask for a free membership that is one
free membership somebody else can't get
we have a nice budget for this I don't
know exactly the total number that we're
giving away but it's a bunch ok so free
memberships half-price memberships for
people who can afford them get in touch
with me david at david pakman.com if you
can afford half price ask for half price
so that we leave the totally free
memberships thanks to Joshua's offer for
people who really can't afford half
price and I look forward to reporting to
you probably by the end of the week both
the free and the half-price memberships
will be spoken for look forward to
reporting to you how many new members we
are able to bring in with this second
month in a row of a great great great
and generous offer
thanks to Joshua more on that later in
the week get in touch